hey what's up I'm gonna be coming to
Newport News Virginia that's right
that's February 29th it's less than a
month away it will sell out the presale
code is onward and those tickets are
available right now at Theo von calm
slash tour so go get those and I'll see
you over there in Virginia beautiful
place beautiful state and today's guests
are well they're two generations of
white rappers musicians entertainers
artists my dear friends simon rex is
here with me today
aka dirk nasty and a young gentleman who
some of you guys might get to know for
the first time is young gravy
[Music]
all right today sitting here with one of
my closest friends in Los Angeles
Simon Rex aka Dirt Nasty happy to be
beside you I'm happy to be here he's
obviously been going through some stuff
though you make me laugh everything and
uh any and truly that one of my one of
my dearest friends in in Los Angeles and
and then a young rapper right here young
gravy is here today greetings
so no gravy yep and how is it previously
Noah
yeah previously known as what what were
you some of y'all's I'm first of all
white rat you guys are white I'm just
gonna say you guys are white rappers
well no I'm jus I did my DNA test I'm
I'm Jewish so not technically white
although I look white and I have white
privilege but I'm not technically white
and I also found out report Meister so
no I'm part I'm part Spanish so if you
want to be racist that's close enough
you're Basque to be specific Basque to
be I was gonna get you're right I'm
Basque which is a region next to Spain
so look and or or Oh what everybody we
had a god these two brought around our
neighborhood on this little spatula a
little Spanish horse and it was like um
like some people had real horses in our
area and people would ride him around
sometimes Louisiana yeah
we're talking rural yeah more rural you
know that gnarly [ __ ]
people like burnin stuff in the yard
often people like what we talkin to
incest or not hmm
because I've been through a few parts of
Georgia where I've well we'll get to
that later but yeah I know you have a
line in one of your song it's like
incest uh incest I just kissed yeah
something yeah yeah there's stories
behind all that [ __ ] it's all oh yeah
I never practice any incest one of us if
my younger sister pretty cute but uh but
she uh ha everybody went their own
separate ways you know that was the
thing so I don't think anybody in our
family hung out long enough to really
practice anything Wow and you didn't
have a sister Sam no I'm only child
which is a core issue of a lot of my
issues
now I gotta know about white rap and I
want to know cuz white rapping seems
like there's a glass ceiling on it it
seems like it's like what does that mean
again yeah I don't know for that term a
lot it has to do with like women in like
the workplace yeah it seemed like you
can only get so high in the genre does
it seem like that in does it seem like I
don't know and this is just my
perceptions and I have no idea I think
nowadays white to be a black rappers
like damn that's a black rapper it's
rare now yeah there's so many different
there's so many different parts of
hip-hop and so many different fan bases
where it's like I mean any rapper no
matter what race they they have like
there's there's a there's black rappers
that have all white fans there's white
rappers that have like a bunch of black
fans it's like it's all over yeah yeah
yeah it's just it's just the finna take
these off yet yeah yeah can we all
switch one one time and then and then
I'll have those yeah so they're
prescription
okay and I want to see you in my glasses
and then we'll go look good on you
really yeah oh thanks man I have a big
nose so I feel like every time I put on
glasses it's like oh this guy's trying
to be in a disguise and then it's like I
just thought you look pretty bro thanks
man you look good man glass ceiling we
got the definition right here
unofficially acknowledged barrier to
advancement in a profession especially
affecting women and members of
minorities which in rapper which in if
people think a rap regular people I'm a
regular person so I think a rap is more
of us like almost like a black sport a
lot of times so do does it seem like
they're like as a white rapper it's like
tougher it doesn't even matter and it
might've been different whenever
something you write well it was
different I can't believe I'm about to
say this but 15 years ago when I came
out with Mickey Avalon and we did a you
know right when myspace came out it was
a novelty it was like oh these white
rappers they're trying to be the Beastie
Boys it wasn't as common 15 years later
I think it's a lot more common but like
we met recently and he was like man you
know I grew up watching your [ __ ] and
then I thought I met little Dickey about
a couple years ago and he said the same
thing and I'm like oh I think it's kind
of evolved to remember little Dickey
saying without my dick there'd be no
little Dickey yeah I mean I think it all
kind of
oh yeah he told me that he was cool at
Sandler Adam Sandler's Christmas party
he pulled me aside and was like dude now
that you guys let me do me so I think it
all lends to each other so but did it
seem like you couldn't did it seem like
you did you feel like a rapper cuz you
are me something you've had a bunch of
different careers and you've had like
you know like you're always you're kind
of an entertainer I mean I'm just trying
to think like I guess I'm just trying to
get a little bit more into it like does
it seem like there was like a ceiling
does it did you feel like there's a
rapper did you feel like I'm kind of an
interesting way to explain it for me
when I first started rapping I had a job
in cause I didn't want to lose it was
like I was like basically I worked at a
startup accelerator which is like they
help like startup companies get off the
ground and I would do all the marketing
for these adventure capitalist people I
don't know how I got that job I was it
would have been dope after school if I
didn't do the rap thing but learning
office marketing [ __ ] whatever so I
wanted to hide my I don't want my boss
to figure out that I raps I didn't want
like yeah it was kind of embarrassing I
don't wanna be that guy yo listen to my
raps so like oh yeah the first like
three months that I was making music I
didn't show anybody everything like my
two roommates and then and then like I
started going up but I kept my my face I
didn't reveal my face for like a year
and a half did you wear a mask or
something or did you well I didn't put
your hand in I didn't pay for him
because I come up on Soundcloud so
that's a slow grind no no you don't need
a face yeah yeah I was every every
single thing I put out was just like
pin-up girls that was like all my art
workers all of his fifties sixties
themed [ __ ] and then finally like I
eventually revealed my face and like I
put off this music video for my biggest
song not mr. clean mm-hmm and it had me
in it and people had like 80% of the
comments like holy [ __ ] I thought he was
black I didn't know he was white so it
was like just cuz of my low voice and
all that it's almost like it's almost
like people were like oh like it was it
was some weird comments oh now that I
figured out that he's white like now
it's like it's like why would you say
what what so there's some where some
white people out there man but like I
feel like I feel like as long as your
musics unique man there's no like like
no glasses I mean look at I mean post
Malone was kind of more like pop but
like he's a white dude and he's like
he's great with yeah Mac Miller personal
I mean Mac Miller I think is the best
example he's like an amazing rapper
respected by everybody yeah and I and
you're in a lot of your videos so you
keep it pretty diverse you keep it real
I mean out even age wise in your videos
they always got like kind of like a
little bit of a lady that you know it's
a little bit older you know I got the
milf thing yeah yeah you do
oh yo yeah you didn't know the lyrics
though that's been my thing yes oh
really love milfs
yeah so I'm saying I've seen some really
on my damn but he's got a real diverse
cuz you love like a 19 year old and then
you'll have like a 49 year old do you
know Brandi love ah ever seen her on the
internet I don't think that a point that
sounds like a point one of the most
famous porn stars on earth Simon might
now he seems a little disappointed that
we don't know yeah yeah oh yeah here she
is right here oh yeah yeah she looks
like every other oh she's a MILF oh no
mom erection stands for it
me and her a really tight she was in a
video of mine I'm sure I've seen it then
yeah I mean it's not one of the most
popular videos but she's she's she's
great and you know we hung out a couple
times yeah yeah I don't think you find
her on YouTube probably in a different
site but the video oh yeah I'm a fan of
young gravy's music here I think he's
awesome
yeah tell me it's so crazy cuz yesterday
I was uh you guys ran into each other
right and yesterday you know he I did
him to watch the Super Bowl if I seem a
little down to dates cuz my 49ers lost
but I'm getting over it it's okay and I
won't talk to you you're Saints fan you
guys had it worse than us so and I bet I
bet in Minnesota a 500 on the on the
Chiefs so he was there all sad and I'm
like trying to hide must know he made it
worse when that they lost and then he
like patted me on the shoulder like made
it worse but yeah so in for his my
bookie account to update and if it's
made you know anyway so yeah I invited
him over to watch the end of the game at
my boys house and then he came back to
the crib and he's like yo you heard a
Theo von I was like you mean one of my
best friends yeah he's like yeah I'm
doing his podcast tomorrow and I said I
got call him and that's awesome in a
small world I was just because we're
thinking like it would be fun to have
somebody else in with you so we're
thinking maybe a comedian and then once
it's warm yet oh oh this is yeah and
what you said that I was thinking my
Trevor Wallace or someone who's mad cool
but like this is this is perfect
like my [ __ ] uncle and you know
Trevor Wallace yeah Trevor's really
really funny man I love I don't need
Trevor knows how big of a fan of him I
have you had a munch at all we should
all hang out yeah yeah no I'd love to
mana I saw him at the comedy store the
other night
yeah he's his [ __ ] on insta gonna make
it fun a bang energy and all of the
stuff we energy oh that's fun I don't
know what you're talking about really
good see that he had a bunch of videos
like making fun a white claw and like
and [ __ ] and then he got sponsored by
truly oh and it was the same she with me
I got sponsored by [ __ ] natty light
no drink two for natural light which is
American alcoholic beverage we have beer
family we never said whenever you starts
you had SoundCloud what did you have
what like what did you guys face was it
Wow that's all we had that's what I
started with like that's trying to get
hoes yeah back in seventh grade but for
music you had to either what if you
wanted to get your music out there blue
tube well it was YouTube was kind of
study this oh five so I remember MySpace
do you remember there was the music
player on your homepage where you can
have like your top friends I'm you could
have all Lil Jon oh we put our fingers
right so we put our own music up as a
demo like here check this out and then
myspace Records and Interscope side
Mickey Avalon together and put out a
collab album and then we just that we
took off from there and it was just like
my accident I would hand out our seat we
I would burn this how old it was I would
burn CDs we'd make demos in my spare
bedroom you buy a burner
ya know - five - could burn five at one
hit or run yeah a burn five CDs of like
five horrible rap songs with me and
Mickey Avalon and Andre legacy and I'd
wrap them up in like the LA Express
which is a local pornographic newspaper
and I'll just hand them out to like
people in LA like Leonardo DiCaprio at
the club I beg here's me and my boys
wrap it it was like what the [ __ ] you
talking and then like a week later
they'd be like that's not you that
sounds dope and it's circulated around
Hollywood and eventually we got sign oh
that's very silly that's crazy because I
was listening to you advertised through
pornography as well yeah oh that was
that was a great movement my mom my
label gave me about five thousand an
advertising budget and we said you know
what let's do
porno so I connected with like this you
know pornhub Aria or it's like the girl
who kind of like I don't pay pretty too
high and stuff I see the a lot of the
free stuff and I'm actually need to get
a block or my she just runs she runs all
the so the the social media for pornhub
connected with her and we got like we
just put all the money into pornhub I
was like let's just [ __ ] do it and
like ads for my new somewhere all over
and people are loving it and like you
know my fanbase is like well now it's a
lot more women but like back then it was
like a lot of dudes so they're just
freaking out the girls were going to
watch porn I feel that coz of it you
know I'm saying as I'm posting about it
yes I was it was a mutually beneficial
thing for me it's yeah it's the same
thing it sound like the st. you guys
just did the same thing that's what's
crazy you write up in something sex you
gotta trick them you got it like disarm
them with a hard penis well not the
heartbeat you want to get them you know
what I'm saying
yes yeah absolutely and I've also had
porn stars in almost all my music videos
so it's like people will see that and
recognize it because it he's with Gina
Valentina he's with brandi Love he's
with Alina Koshka but I haven't no idea
any of those three names I think I'm too
old because I I don't know those names
y'all sure he made me get the porn block
on my phone yeah I still happen I can't
delete it off for them what's porn blog
mixes you can't access porn
oh [ __ ] y'all get 27 he doesn't need to
know yet yeah I'm in the future dude I'm
you oh yeah Simon is you like 12 years
where you're already you're 27
I'm not I'm 39 oh but Simon is you have
27 aren't you 23 23 I'm like a grown man
it's the height only 23 he's a child
well you could be a grandfather and
father brought be your dad dude you're
my uncles I'm 45 I'm your uncle but I'm
just saying legally I could be your dad
anyway better so listen to this my mom
parents I know my parents had a 21 year
gap and they're really old for parents
my dad had been married before so my mom
is 62 and my dad would be 84 he passed
away he passed away when I was 16
oh man said it might have an I was 16 we
have colon cancer he I know you fell in
the ice
it was it was rough man but like it
really it really did like affect my like
career like motivate me and I was like
y'all and he become the man of the house
my mom couldn't really handle it I was
like become the man of the house and I
was like you know I need to like I'd
give me so much motivation to like it
like you know like impress him and like
support my mom and like I think that
definitely helped me it's where I'm at
now and and it did yeah I mean at first
of all I can definitely like I didn't
have that experience of my dad but I but
yeah I could imagine if my family was
kind of tight and that happened you know
and it cuz you're being tall like when
you're tall you you guys can't hide from
like any it's like if you're tall
immediately I feel like oh you got to do
something everybody else looks at tall
people to do something yeah I can tell
something yeah help out around the house
yeah help out take on the responsibility
no I'm saying if you had like a short
brother nobody seemed like hey you know
Ernie and I had I had only half siblings
that were like 30 years older huh
so what I was doing was [ __ ] I mean I
was just like grinding hardest [ __ ]
school trying getting to college at all
that my by myself with my mom couldn't
really she was just you know shade that
period of time and you never knew that
about that makes me respect and like you
more and that's maybe the deep voice
comes from having to be a man sooner
because he has a very deep man you never
know oh yeah I bet if you reach in his
throat you find a couple of [ __ ]
scrotum in there bro oh no but your own
PC could be anybody you know yeah yeah
you're right bro the glass ceiling in
there it could be a beautiful chick with
some solid nuts on yeah that's that next
level man I got a I got a toaster I
really really quick rocked a name who I
was with but I was in Germany on tour
and you know have you all ever been in
Germany for like the the prostitution
area I've been to Germany but not for
prostitute okay I'm gonna Amsterdam and
I've experienced some of the well calf
to offer cuz I wanted to see what like I
just wanted to go see what's all about
and like me and a good friend and
another good friend we're on tour there
a while back and we went into like a
they basically have this whole street
where it's like all these hotels it's
like four or five of them but they're
all it's in Hamburg
they're all just like every hotel room
has its own prostitute and you walk up
and like literally it's like the like
oh yeah like 30 euro like sucking [ __ ]
like they're like barely even speaking
English crazy but we were just going
there to check it out we weren't even
trying to like I mean someday I want to
say that I that I [ __ ] a hooker but no
hasn't happened yet but we're going up
in there we get to the top anymore man
we did we didn't know what the top floor
was what that meant so we're walking
down this hallway and there's like all
the doors are closed but all right
what's going on and the way I'm no cat
we're at the end of the hallway there's
this like like probably like 50 to 60
year old lady like she looks really nice
she looks like a [ __ ] mom like a nice
mom she's like smiling at us we're like
a and we're just like waving like
walking towards her and then she just
gets up whips up her skirt big-ass dick
and she's just like swinging it back and
forth and like smiling and like laughing
and were like it was it was it was
almost like a like a scary scene from it
was like what pop out seeing a movie
were like like oh man like we just
[ __ ] turn around and Manesh it was
like she got a lot of I'm not a bit at
least he's somebody dick is surprising
if you look at it is that what a dick
surprising when you when was a white
woman it was a yep probably 55 year old
white woman who was but who was a man
she never chose the penis yeah I think
it's a dude but he looked just like a
like a nice grandma not a woman that
attached it looked like a woman who
would be really good at making cookies
and she pulled our roller and then he
pulls up and whips his [ __ ] out we're
just like man this is welcome to Germany
bro was it stock or was it aftermarket
yeah dude that's you know what's crazy
is I went to Germany one time with my
ex-girlfriend it wasn't going really
well and we were like there's for
camping and [ __ ] it wasn't good but
anyway outside of that we were driving
through a park on a bicycle one time
riding on him and some man popped out
from behind a tree I guess you can be
naked in certain area of the park and
just shook his like got his hips going
just shook his penis back and forth and
was bouncing it off his legs like a
soccer ball and it was hop of it and he
just just for fun I mean probably the
craziest it was almost like he had taken
and it seemed like it wasn't a penis at
first I keep you could see it from real
far away that's how
Oh weird a huge oh it was very big but
when he got when we got closer he was
like literally like you see like one of
those Spanish gals like bouncing a ball
on their way it was they all worked out
he was like there he wasn't even trying
to scare you he was just out there like
doing his morning like know he was
surprising it was over hop out and scare
you type of thing but then was so he
gets off on that I bet that's not sexual
it seems like but it was it was like
choreographed clearly and he knew what
he was doing yeah he was waiting for
bikers to come then he popped down and
did it and my girl I was seeing actually
did a loop back around and saw it again
before we met because I've never heard
it there's a lot of things I find out
through your podcast that I that I can't
tell whether you told me or I heard it
on the podcast because I'm a fan of
Theo's as well as a friend so I never
know how to separate the two because I
listen to you on the road of life I'm
always on the road and you're I stay a
part of my life we stay in touch on the
phone and check in my lives in the pod
and I never know what's told and what
from you or the pot right wonder what
yeah yeah one day you were telling me a
story where you tell me story about the
other day man so many dad is about your
dad oh that yeah we did acid it might
have been it yeah I did a sit with my
dad I did LSD with my dad I'm about to
do DMT with my mom really see I think
doing psychedelic with your parents is
the new [ __ ] cuz it's not like you were
gonna party do it it's more like a
bonding chemical and half therapeutic
healing what happened when you did it
super close and your father's from New
Orleans is my dad's from New Orleans
yeah I actually found that out while we
were on acid I thought he was from
Atlanta Howard wait your whole my whole
life I never knew he was from New
Orleans yeah so and that's where my
parents met is in New Orleans oh right
so that's why we have a kindred yeah
yeah so my dad asked me to send him some
LSD in the mail because he recently had
some health issues and I had some then I
hadn't done LSD in like 20 years and I
just happened to have some I was like he
asked me if I could get it like yeah dad
actually do have some and I sent it to
him in the mail and I was on tour and I
had a day off and I drove to visit him
in Nashville he's like do you want to do
some of that acid that you sent me and I
was like [ __ ] no and then I was like
Asheville North Carolina yeah yes we
lives now like he's a southerner who
does that people love that you like yeah
so we did some together and
walked around and spent the day together
what happened I said what type of ass
liquid LSD that was on a mint so it was
[ __ ] oh yeah up in Minnesota we would
get like the the bunk like five our
lasting ones there likes us like back in
high school I was doing the ones where
you taste it and you still do it
no no it was this is very very clean
good you could uh you could eat on it
you could sleep on it it was very good
quality and did y'all put yeah it was a
DDoS on a mint we've got a mint put them
in so we did like half a hit each right
and that's us too I'll put you there but
it's not like you're seeing the walls
melt and you're tripping out it's more
just like it's hard to explain man it's
just if you've done it people listening
if you've done it you know anyway so we
just start telling me all this crazy
[ __ ] that I never knew about our side of
the family and about my uncle that
committed suicide and about all the did
we have depression in our if all these
things started to make sense that I
never knew but while on LSD was really
extra crazy you know yeah and he started
a good feeling it was it was it was just
very intense it wasn't good or bad it
was just like what it was like you know
when you get your mind blown but then
imagine being on LSD while you're
getting your mind blowing like wait a
minute like I didn't even need to be on
acid to hear all this [ __ ] was weird
enough and then he told me that his dad
my grandfather was like a spiritual like
leader who opened up like a cult
basically and had all these women that
he was sleeping with that he took
advantage of his power and was kind of
like this like like you see those cult
documentaries about a guy who he
intended to be a God like he said my
grant and I was just like wait I can't
take my grandfather that I never met he
renamed himself Rama which is like a
religious name but he was like a
southern do with an accent but renamed
himself Roma and [ __ ] a bunch of women
some heavy [ __ ] yeah yeah you couldn't
do that nowadays did he write a movie
that because it sounds when people do
that all the time you could do it
nowadays but you would be on blast a
little more this was in the 60s or
something when he was older in life or
maybe even the 50s so he got away with
it cuz you could get away with
everything up until 1989 or whatever
year the cellphone technology started
coming our internet you know what I mean
like back in the day was it crazy to
like we used to get like did it man I'm
wondering what it would be like if I was
with mama cuz it would be your pop what
are you gonna say I was just yeah if
y'all got a DMT or acid good acid plug I
need to bring some back to my mom
because like we nowadays like like she's
retired it's so chill man I'll go back
have all the friends overall party shook
him spoke with us well whatever before
the bar isn't after trick I'm hit shots
my mom is so funny FaceTime she's cool I
met his mama we are I'm she this week
biggest sweetheart and she really wants
to do DMT no we'll talk after okay
perfect yeah you had something your
fries you show me what time amazing LSD
it looked like that was the one that was
the one I set my dad Wow yeah that one
bottle yeah I kind of just gave most of
it away because it's not something yeah
exactly it's not something you do all
the time I mean maybe one a couple times
a year maybe three times so I gave
almost all of it away to a lot of people
because we do strange looking at it like
on your pet like I'm yeah yeah my mom
one I feel like when I look at a let's
see a purse at one point I look real
like young and vibrant and then later as
it goes on I start to squirrel out my
dad look likes always like that's really
like my dad start looking really weird
to me cuz you know they say don't look
in the mirror and then I was looking at
my dad I'm like woah I came out of his
yeah I'm half him that's me like I start
tripping on just like the biology of you
know handed down it was cool but no it
wasn't bad it was just weird
he was weed oh yeah he thought would be
weird but it was good in the end in the
end it was a bomb it was a good thing in
the end yeah did you guys have like any
like was there any like do you guys
connect on any new level you thought
yeah I think we did which was very
helpful it sounds crazy but since he was
opened like it was his suggestion I
didn't suggest it was his idea and at
first I was reluctant them like wait
that's actually a good idea because he
was never I was never close to my dad so
yeah good thing he's getting older and I
think you know he wants to you know
connect with his son so we did it as a
sort of a like therapeutic you know it
was crazy
yeah because interesting cuz yeah it's
like a lot of times you do I feel like
well it takes me back to thinking like
in tribes and stuff people used to
probably do that kind of stuff more
often like have those sweat lodges
itself family and eat peyote or do
something wild or do something you know
you know things were a lot more you saw
people in their in their reality or they
were probably trying to get [ __ ] up
together like as families probably
people I don't know stuff okay adding to
what you're saying I don't think it's
getting [ __ ] up I think there was
rites of passage yeah every single
culture up until every culture
throughout history almost has had some
rite of passage and we don't we go to
the military or maybe if you're Jewish
you have a Bar Mitzvah you do you might
go to college but you become a
man somehow but really not through any
type of spiritual like drug in the noon
you lose your virginity oh that's the
way to become when did you I lost my
virginity at 15 but it was horrid and
then I remember losing my virginity
thinking oh I get laid all the time and
then I didn't get laid for two more
years yes Cynthia Dan Lee I hope I could
say that on the air legally did you play
as Cynthia that's [ __ ] oh that's
beautiful actually I could be your uncle
I'll be uncle uncle dirt yeah I lost
mine at 14 oh yeah if these kids are
advanced o Orakei are people I feel like
kids now are probably going lower too
cuz I feel like I get deems from kids
they're like fourteen talking about like
we didn't like all this [ __ ] that like I
guess I guess that's one I supposed we
still it's like a lot of kids you know I
smoked weed back then too but like I
don't know Wendy was like was a little
bit of all yeah I think sex was more
like seventeen there was like one couple
we heard had sex when they were like in
eighth grade and everybody people drawn
pictures of them for like months and
like all excited people would like run
up and touch the guy on his back and
everywhere God what do you mean what guy
the guy who'd had sex is there anything
was ever so like yeah like [ __ ] it
was so cool they always want to touch
him yeah boy Nathan and people would in
his he I remember this kid he always
said his name was spelled the same
backwards and forwards and it wasn't
dude and he thought it was Nathan Nathan
oh yeah that's an amount appear no I
would write wrong thousand times I wrote
it at school conundrum there's no way
and every time I wrote it it didn't add
a palindrome thank you the voice of
reason it's like God coming Terminator
that keeps popping up on the other side
of the wall uhit's elevator oh it's an
elevator
that's what elevators a device that
takes you from floor another story God
tells when I did some drugs with my
uncle
oh [ __ ] with me mm-hmm members where'd
you guys get out in so you know he's
been my [ __ ] idol like oh you really
mean me I think you met your real I am
real yeah I have really Azon yeah girl
all my grandparents died before over
one died before I was born uncles all
live in Switzerland and they're all dead
now I have like one uncle in America
like my family's old and like Swiss oh
oh look Swiss you do bright you okay you
be Santa Claus his grandson you could be
a game of Thrones like King I'm swimming
I'm from my gran this the Italian part
is Michelin some Italian Swiss a little
bit French you look like an entitled
millionaire Prince from the border of
Switzerland and like Michigan Michigan
yeah yeah close I mean yeah yeah you got
no you got a regal DNA I mean yeah yeah
Oh your to be Minnesota okay okay yeah
we didn't talk about it I like Minnesota
though I've had some good times out
there but I want to hear about this
exports yeah I want to hear about this
time you got oh yeah so let me think we
were we had this whole tour I had had
some bad experiences in the past
performing the bay cuz my first show
there ever I got roofied by somebody
that was in the greenroom and it was
like these weird kids from like pretty
sure was these weird kids from from
college there was these kids that paid
us 500 bucks per night to do a
five-minute set opening for our shows
were like were that's 1500 bucks
you go up on stage for a minute but then
the last show we did with them they like
I don't even know all like I took like
four drinks and then all of a sudden
like I'm out I remember it even this is
what my friends were telling me all of a
sudden like like I guess I'm completely
off the shits I go up onstage I start my
song and I'm storing the words and uh
and then I walk off after one song and
I'm like yeah I got a P and then like
the whole crowd is like what and then
like I guess I've passed out in the
bathroom locked the door all this [ __ ]
just someone had put some Sh in my drink
it because he was roofie he was either
roofies are just a shitload of xanax but
I'm pretty sure with roofies he's I got
weird ass weird-ass withdrawals and [ __ ]
so like that was my first experience in
San Francisco and like oh it's whatever
but um yeah yeah I'm a quick
interjection I'm sorry I got work on
interrupting you Theo taught me but I
want to interject roofies is a loose
term that I think is being used
incorrectly you weren't roofied because
those are rohypnol which they don't even
make anymore so when people say got
roofied that people use it loosely like
they put some in my drink but
technically a roofies are all hypno
which you cannot get so I bet you it was
anecdote make them anymore but I sort of
I've been
cribes an X and an X but not really hip
know we're banned I know but like don't
my body handles in it's really well
illegal but not three ladders so I guess
I bet you I'm just saying it interject
I'm sorry I think was annex you continue
this horrible story about Simon's on
some drugs oh I've been really cleanly
anything is always drinking read blog
Gen X tastes like ass I didn't face
anything I won't know what it was
because they don't make rohypnol anymore
but anyway I just want to clear that up
for listeners because everyone's always
like I got roofied I'm like no you
didn't they don't even exist that sec
saying I got quaalude it they don't make
those right so guy I just know about
this stuff so it could have been like a
GHB or something I could've been GH it
could have been GHB the exact was gonna
rape you or anything that's a very one
who know they I think I think these
opener dudes that were pay almost money
wanted to like somehow look better some
weird these are weird one of the one of
them literally faked cancer and made it
go fund me oh my god wow yeah he's like
club promoter type you oh yeah this
horrible opening acts are always catch
you peeping at that's crazy yeah I mean
interrupt I just want to clear the air
on man no look it's interesting because
I didn't know that roofies to the movie
come from rohypnol which has been banned
because it was the date rape drug for so
long they stopped making those you can't
even get fake rohypnol anywhere they do
a lot of people stopped dating when they
stopped making so I said yeah at a show
in Santa Cruz coming up and I was like
oh man like the last 10 accrue show I
had the green room is shitty whatever
it'll be fun but out but then I was like
that's your that's your territory yeah
preying grounds yeah so I was like bro
like let me have [ __ ] Simon come open
for me and then we'll do a show together
and then oh yeah yeah so we went out
there it was [ __ ] dope and then like
it was that the first time we met
normally I think we have met once
briefly and heavily met in LA in Venice
we went and I took the Erawan right and
then II think um open up for me which I
did which was a disaster and itself
because I opened up for you and I gave
him all the hits 1980 my dick all the
good songs and the whole crowd just
stared at me like get this old dude out
of here and I remember thinking oh like
it was bad you had to come out and save
me you came out onstage and did my dick
with me and we're like don't you guys
know who this is
that's Dirt Nasty and I was just like
this sucks and and 957 people
- staring at me like get this dude out
of here now members thinking oh my god
this is so crazy I'm the old dude in
front of a bunch of 1700 kids that don't
know who Dirt Nasty is it was a good
humbling experience yeah
and then I proceeded to get butt-fucked
drunk waste we were doing this before
the show we were drinking things we're
so excited to be together and I had all
the DMT so literally before before
either of us go on we both took and ate
the shrooms no I would not would even
been able to stand no I didn't I did my
I did my our set tripping but I swear I
got in you know oh I might have got him
for you but I didn't do them I did not I
do everybody must all the goods and then
some some we're drinking tequila at that
little barn you bought the tab yeah yeah
and then some wookie dude had cake look
we were doing hey dude so we were on K
alcohol weed [ __ ] shrooms and DMT DMT
I was doing DMT back there cause II was
dude he's going to the gym later the
olives I love DMT it's my favorite it's
done that like few times but I did get
drunk and get put in the hole I do that
okay I did for me I did all of them Wow
and then and then you do yours that I
come out early and then you go and pass
out in the greenroom and then I'm on
stage and the shrooms are starting to
hit me I'm like up there man that [ __ ]
was a weird show cuz like apparently
like everyone on my team and like people
don't work they were like you know
what's going on like what's wrong with
this dude like why is he acting weird
but like the Pratt the crowd didn't know
cuz I'm on my show they loved it still
but I was just like they thought I was
joking I'd be like yo like are we inside
right now but I keep seeing like stars
like is that a bird like I was excited
like that and like everyone just kind of
thought it was funny like like the crew
but they're like bro he's off some [ __ ]
right now you know Santa Cruz
understands yeah but but the kids the
kids were younger and they loved the
show still but I was loved it remember
being on stage and I was just like every
once in a while I'd be like god [ __ ]
damn dude I'm really on stage tripping
on shrooms seeing things all these
people are looking at me
it was a weird feeling man I probably
won't forget you're sure any of the
words or anything like that uh I don't
think I forgot words but apparently I
took like an insane amount of water
breaks I don't know why like I don't
know but I don't know which one of those
drugs would do that it was just like
they're like yeah everything every song
is a water brick and I would like walk
over and like you did great I remember
you killed it he didn't sing to the
crowd oh and this is where we're gonna
tie it in two big dogs to do to you
big dogs yeah oh yeah big day big day
can you name it a moment of silence for
Big Dave and I was like what's he doing
and he had the whole crowd goes and if
anyone talks they get kicked out and was
a moment of silence for the dude that
you told me you call me up that you've
seen this dude on King pig oinks because
because I'm going out here and uh and in
[ __ ] big doings out here in we're
gonna get it that's New Jersey New
Jersey but [ __ ] big doing rest in
peace
yeah rest in peace so it was so funny
you told me about him I had a studio
session when I was like about to sign
her onto a label they were giving
obviously do sessions in New York and I
brought out young King Dave and smoked
her and my dog trippy and we went to the
to the studio he came through with
twenty Dinks he's not capping about the
donkey he's got a lot yeah so we smoked
20 dogs in like two hours and and we're
weird is going off and then I'm like yo
dude I got this record so one of my
favorite tracks off of money my project
I was rapping with my boy baby no money
who's know what potestas song yeah yeah
and he's great yeah he's really doubling
my best friend so really song what is
that welcome to choice yeah yeah love
that was good it was good video to thank
you yeah we got a new video guys well
we'll talk on that later but but I just
had Dave going I was like Brahma loop
this beat is freestyle
like I just go off bro and he was like
you know himself it was so dope he went
off you spat a bunch of [ __ ] bars
some good some bad whatever I like
blended it together and made this verse
at the end of the song and I [ __ ]
love it like it's epic little outro to
our project and then it became a huge
song like I'm for us and all my fans
loved it so every every show we would
have a moment of silence for young king
day before that Solomon play and they're
like people would like to get completely
silent and like if there was ever like
anyone that would make a Pete we'd kick
them out because like let's pull that up
Nick can you pull up yanking gave on
gee I want to see a couple of there he
is New Jersey social media star I think
he honestly did seem like and I'm
guessing here but it seemed like the
smoking is what killed him he was really
big really big it was a heart is that
the song some older ones your hand if
you don't mind yeah you should play you
should play the song with me and him and
butyl money yeah skip like like halfway
through it's called gasoline gasoline
young king Dave I gotta go pee anyway
okay cool
sorry to interrupt but I just want to
let you know today's episode is brought
to you by skills share and it's about I
mean look there's there's a lot of times
I want to do something I want to widdle
something you know I want to do mine
reading or something and I can't because
I don't know how well Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more take classes in social
media marketing photography writing
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
Skillshare is there to keep you learning
thriving and reaching those new goals
are you a freelancer try bookkeeping for
freelancers how to handle your finances
it's one of their most popular courses
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners get
2 months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering this past
weekend listeners 2 months of unlimited
access to over 25,000 classes for free
to sign up go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von again go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo von to start your 2 months
now that Skillshare comm slash Theo von
and now back to the episode
[Music]
that's what that's known TV super
down-to-earth super 19 to ban in all the
videos and stuff in all of his stories
oh cool so nice give the best hugs being
great dude yeah I don't remember how I
got on him
you called me freaking out about him one
day like dude have you seen this guy cuz
you turn me on a smoking 623 that's what
she's the bet we should get around here
one day yeah there he is dude and that's
his boy right there what's his boys name
oh oh man I used to be so in there in
their world Brower like I was always
listening to what they were doing is
seeing how crazy it was I know I don't
personally yeah I manage isn't she a man
[ __ ] legend r.i.p wow man sad and did
it happen so fast huh
mm-hmm yeah I was like someone had said
something about him and like his manager
called me and told me man it was pretty
oh and I had only met him twice but I'm
King Dave let's see what he says right
here I tear
he's rolling down my face don't do that
loud pack spicy [ __ ] hey but like you
know there's a lot of people on
Instagram who we're like doing like some
[ __ ] trying to be like really like
ignorant and different like you know
like like the people like that the neck
dudes and you know your long neck were
there like I don't know the people
personally were there like trying to
like be extra weird in like in some way
like get quiet it was like he wasn't
like he was just being himself man right
funny and like daddy makes some wild
videos but he's a unique character
though I mean his neck is this gooey ham
right here if you paint it in black this
could be him yes who told my daddy long
that damn long net is that the little
skinny vid yeah okay okay yeah I know
evil God I don't know any of it I'm just
like when I see people like like soup so
I love supreme fatty but they like doing
all this [ __ ] like for the yes some of
them yeah it's kind of like a character
thing but it's like he was like just
straight his personality
yeah all the way yeah yeah he was real
you feel what someone putting too much
hot sauce on it you can feel it you know
I mean yeah it's yeah I think yeah a lot
of stuff comes off and yeah
a lot of stuff come to see it a lot of
stuff yeah you can always feel what I
what it seems pretty junior go tell if
something's real or not you know but
some people don't care thing so come
people maybe they're given ometer just
kind of bent out and they'll do whatever
you know you met supreme petty I never
met him he's actually really nice is he
funny so - yeah yes some of his stuff is
pretty crazy I met a guy yesterday who
doesn't stuff with his grandmother and
they have like videos together smile
supreme granny he's a grandma supreme
Patti does it's too much drugs for me oh
he does a lot of drugs yeah they're
always like but him and long that got in
a fight a fistfight yeah you'd have to
use a clamp you know these are put a
chip clamp like one of those cheap them
fresh yeah well why do with the super
long one with the quad net oh that's why
Darrell Darrell did he went to jail
bitty
oh yeah he's from Georgia yeah that one
that guy's yeah yeah David and I accept
family with family are my distant
relatives come on yeah but he uh yes I
know they make those videos out there
but they don't like some of their stuff
is just so the production value is uh
they're like beating each other with
hatchets in like bags of potato chips
actually this time of year yeah we need
like Aqualung to come back yeah well
that's a thing dude if you if you it now
here's what I was thinking was one on
somebody put together of like a Barnum &
Bailey type of circus
ooh with these unique characters of
people dude and take them on tour that's
the best idea you've had all day thank
you thank you but I don't know what
other ideas you've had but that's a good
one I've met any yeah take him on the
road here we got a question that came in
right here from some from some gentleman
we just mentioned beef this is a
question about possible beefy on gravy
ass oh Jesus Christ
yo gravy do you have beef with shotgun
Willie cuz when he dropped Wendy I
remember you posted on your story that
he copied the beat of Wendy from magic
so are these goons shotgun Willie is he
a cartoon of the
no it's a real guys real guy I'm not
shocked I'm really so so I had this song
that I've been hyping up for like two
years but I couldn't there was all these
legal issues cuz it was a Perry Como
sample and the Perry Como estate like
obviously I'm rapping about [ __ ] moms
they're not like they're not gonna clear
it so then I had to go through all this
process of like getting reap that
replayed and all this stuff and know
what that is when I think they take a
sample like you ever heard magic moments
with Perry Perry Como man there's magic
oh no it's like 20s
I don't know but anyways I was sampling
it was a great sample but I couldn't I
couldn't release it without getting sued
so then I've been hyping this stuff up
on my story all the time and then he
puts one out with that sample and it's
like the exact same flow that I had on
the song that I previewed a bunch but
then like I don't I don't know if he
copied it from here if he just thought
of it himself but then like I'm not
meeting the guy he's he's really cool so
that's oh no it's a compliment no beef
with shotgun Willie okay yes we don't
want you having beef because we don't
want him to get into one of these
altercations with anyone that would hurt
him yeah yeah well people don't hurt me
I hurt too many people when I go to jail
and I break my hand and [ __ ] so I this
next tour I'm hiring someone that's not
necessarily security but it's like a a
big person he was either security or
like stop drunk Matt from fighting
people oh really I've had a lot of like
I've done that too many times yeah are
you one of those humans that can turn
like I feel he could maybe snap and go
from nice guy to elbow to the face
pretty quick you get me a soda you guys
do that for me for me it's like it's
like if anything comes out that's like I
have I have a lot of like if most of the
altercations I've been in were because
someone was being racist to a friend of
mine and then like when that happens
like I never I never throw the first
punch like I'll always like get get them
pissed off I also like have so I don't
mind mine frat dudes but sometimes if I
say take a douchey Frakker I'll just
kind of like like [ __ ] with them a
little bit like make fun of them or
something until they get pissed off
thing is when I'm drunk I don't know why
I like to like start show like that it's
fun for me I got to stop because I broke
my hand and I can read break it pretty
easily did you break it on what a wall
on someone oh I broken I broke it on
tour actually in New Zealand and I was
just across the front I don't know what
the [ __ ] gave me the ham but I just got
hit
and really hard but like I've been in
like a ton of fights not at this point I
need just chill out yeah you have too
much lives now yeah he has a Tesla we
came in here together in it yeah less
car but like for me it's it's not really
yeah he drove Tesla automatic drive was
hands up he's like I hope this doesn't
make you nervous and he hit auto driving
I kind of I got it I was nervous I was
nervous damn he the car was driving
itself as he was texting anybody told
you forewarned me but that's what these
kids do he's 23 oh yeah who knows what
he's doing
yeah man but I'm I gotta have someone
around me just be like yo don't do that
no don't find other people cuz cuz for
me it's like I'm sawing off or if it's a
drunk kid and then like I could throw
one really hard haymaker and knock
somebody out easily like I had a friend
who knocks someone out too hard
Minnesota and they died and went to jail
for six oh [ __ ] so how do rappers like
how do rappers like collaborate with one
another like do you guys hit each other
up on the like did you did you guys do
any collaborations was going to we're
going to you can I speak on that he hit
me on Twitter similar to how we met I
met some of my best friends on social
media and as much as we hate social
media sometimes you make amazing friends
on Twitter and Instagram and it ain't
just about getting laid and talking [ __ ]
you can actually like make good truth
good friends like you too
he hit me up just like you I hit you up
and next thing you know I'm subletting
my home to him and he's like I need a
place to stay in LA i'ma get a hotel I'm
like just take my crib I'll be in Asia
just told me a little loot and take the
crib for a month so he did he helped me
out I kind of needed the loot he needed
a place and next thing you know he's in
my home and I'm like telling my
neighbors yo my boy staying over and
we're now we're friends and we're gonna
do a song together eventually we just
haven't yet hmm long-winded maybe some
TV [ __ ] yeah yeah I want to produce a
show for me yes a good eye for like just
I don't know man he just says his tastes
are really usually spot-on like he's
introduced me to so many things that I
love you know yeah how do you like how
do you figure out like is it weird to
figure out how to go from like doing
music into entertainment does it even
matter anymore do you think it was
different whenever you were you were
rapping a lot of sound so real quick
when you're asking about meeting other
people to collaborate
funny story me and baby no money who
like now I was like my yeah I've seen
him is literally
we're like like brothers in the [ __ ]
rap industry dropping a whole project
very soon that's like we've done 20-plus
songs together anyways I met him on
soundcloud I had a hundred and like 20
followers and he had 200 that's like
nothing he DM me
he's a Gil man your shit's dope and like
literally from nothing we like became
tight I started helping him with his
style he helped me with some things
mixing in all this [ __ ] and like now
we're like best friends I were touring
the world together and stuff it's crazy
how that type of [ __ ] can happen but
literally like that little amount of
follower is just crazy how early it
started reminds me so much Micky and
legacy he's doing exactly what me making
legacy did I see it I'm like dude
there's having fun you can hear through
the song it's contagious they're not
being taking themselves too serious but
they can rap and it's fun and I'm
attracted to that that's what I like I
want to have fun I don't want to be you
know isn't some thuggish [ __ ] him you
know but like they're having fun and
they can rap I love it yeah woohoo did
you guys ever um did you guys ever work
with other artists song yeah Lots I got
I mean I could I always tell people like
I could retire tomorrow I did a song
with too short I did I did a song with 2
Live Crew and I met the ghetto boys and
worked with them those are my three
favorite rappers I grew up on I'm like
if you would have told me at any point
in my life that I'd be working with my
three favorite like people who inspired
my style I'd be like get the [ __ ] out of
here there's no way so it could be over
tomorrow and I did it but somehow I
still keep like meeting people like him
and working it's just crazy like same
thing with me exactly what my favorites
have always been Juicy J young thug
action bronson met all of them did his
song with Juicy J got one of the works
with Action Bronson like oh I'm gonna
bring you to Alchemist because he's
action Bronson's dude and I'm always
over at Al's and I just would tell him
about a little about you the other day
so I always got like me and Ally always
finding new [ __ ] that I got to bring you
to ask cuz that'll be a dope collab do
you start to find that you're like so it
do you start to find that you're more of
an artist than a rapper do you start to
find that you're more of an entertainer
than a rapper I'm just kind of curious
as to how like it it expands from one
into the other some people stay exactly
in one medium you know you mean when you
say entertainer do you trying to say
like like touring and all like an actor
like a
possible like a you know host oh okay
did you get into other types of system
for me right now all I've done is is
literally like mute like writing my own
music and then doing stuff for like
sinks for like TV and and commercials
and stuff and then I've done writing for
other artists I've done pretty much just
music stuff but I want to get in Adult
Swim's talk to me and like there's you
know kung fury kung fury now we're out
of that no you're moving oh that's crazy
well oh yeah yeah I know there's some
movies coming out but that's not a new
movie yeah yeah but they're potentially
making a sequel oh okay okay it's kind
of a like a cheesy yeah and they're
making a few of the movies that like
that like I'm gonna be doing more yeah
oh that movie's amazing you should watch
it you're gonna be enacted look like to
answer your question for me I can only
speak for myself I came into rap way
after I was doing hosting and acting and
all these things just because in
Hollywood if you just put all your eggs
in one basket and wait for the phone to
ring you're gonna go crazy
yeah I always had now on podcasting I do
music I do acting I'll host whatever I
do all that [ __ ] for him heat right now
as an MC I know I don't wanna speak for
me but tell me if I'm wrong you're
coming into the game as a rapper but
he's gonna end up doing some like TV
he's gonna be like I don't know who to
compare you to but I could see you
totally getting into comedy and you
could do whatever he's got the whole
package I think because he's funny dude
he's a funny yeah I know I was gonna
maybe be a hadn't offered to just like
voice a guest appearance on Rick and
Morty and then I miss my flight
oh yeah so that now you know that that
would have been the first one I'm over
the heat on my own one time I missed a
whole weekend of shows I'm close to I'd
set my phone alarm I'd got drunk and
slept on my phone and then urinated on
it damn come back in the early 2000 yeah
this like my first phone yes probably
about 2000 maybe not it's like a Nokia
set about it cuz then by that time by
the time I got up I miss my fighting
they're like I just don't quit on my
phone why didn't every come from five
years that club would let me come for
five years and I have a so I pissed on
my phone while texting and like pissing
before but I just like trying to multi
yeah yeah yeah but I've I have a really
gnarly story oh I want to hear that you
cut things out huh
yeah if it's too gnarly whoa okay so
it's gonna meet you normally bomb I tell
you guys anyways so I have this there's
just girl that wasn't for a while she
was like kind of my girlfriend but like
we were really tight this was way back
in like late high school maybe early
college I don't know why I felt the need
to do this but I was like just learning
about the the nofap [ __ ] I'm ready oh if
you don't jerk off you're gonna get
increased testosterone brain power
whatever so I hadn't I hadn't jerked off
for like thirty days I was like out of
out of the state or something like that
like I'm home yeah that's not easy then
I came home and I was with her I started
hooking up so hooking up and I'm I'm in
it for like 45 seconds and it's it's
that time and I was like man it's gonna
be a high yield so I pull out and I'm
like I don't know what came about me I
was just doing my like furious like
about a nut zone and I just like aimed
for her dresser and just came all over
her like wallet and phone and all of her
like I just like a big it was disgusting
and I felt so horrible after I'm like
I'm sorry I don't know why today but I
just like noted on her phone [ __ ] like
like watch like wallet like no whole kit
Bertil keys I was just like no like for
one second I became like an evil villain
and then it was just like 30 days of no
no nuts and you couldn't even enjoy the
nut cuz you've probably a good person
and you felt guilty while coming no no I
felt great will come so that was yeah
let everyone keep that look it's
something yet happens it's hard
sometimes if you don't know how much nut
is inside of your body
I know wet it was more than I'd ever
yeah I know wet I'd to wet dreams the
last six months did you really yeah yeah
creative I know I'm 45 oh that's a maze
I know I told my therapist you're 45 30
I'm 39 but you know she'd enter a
contest bro if you do they're like a
they should have a wet dreamers contest
where you get to watch them on like a
like a kind of like a dark cam or
whatever at night and you see the guys
yeah yeah I woke up laughing both times
and it's crazy because that's usually
what happens as a teenager I mean let's
be real ones last time you had wet
dreams don't think I've ever
you haven't he's gonna owe you Swedish
though yeah it's an Icelandic region
y'all you're almost I think it's a sub
if you're dumb as close as [ __ ] well I
think it's a great thing to do because I
I've done the nofap thing he got me on
the porn block which I still have on my
phone which is you know that's cool it's
cool but it's not but I and so it builds
up sometimes in I have a wet dream and I
she was crazy robots were sucking my two
at the same time they're on the crank
there are Asian girls which I'm not
attracted to but I don't even be racist
I'm just not attracted to Asian women
yeah and they were both on a crank
system oh are they robots yeah they were
like faking their Asian people have a
very sometimes a lot of some Asian
people Japanese people have a very
robotic sense of style sometimes we
almost hit one and what did I tell you
in the parking lot she had no emotion
too almost getting run over by a
previously she was driving it wasn't
auto drunk but in a good way it was like
she was like she's not gonna freak out
like I sacrifice someone go to heaven or
wherever and I'm gonna come right back I
need to become what's up with a crazy
asian girl there craisins yeah I thought
she was awesome man I don't know I don't
know robot experiences it is that raised
it no I don't think nowadays
everything's racist but I just don't
find as so those weird that I had the
dream so maybe subconsciously and there
are crank system oh I can't believe I
love that it's organized well I think
maybe my inability to have wet dreams is
like sometimes I'll have a morning wood
that lasts like 45 in that crazy it's
[ __ ] up like that happened this
morning and I just moved into this new
or I'm staying with some some new some
people that I don't know that well and
I'm like trying to go take a piss no a
shower and I'm like man I can't leave
this room because we're all in the same
floor or this there's one bath I'm like
dude I'm gonna walk out there with my
[ __ ] like straight up like it's yeah
they wouldn't go away it was literally
30 to 40 minute I would drink some of
your blood just to have that kind of
activity in my penis but you know you
know [ __ ] have like six six [ __ ]
drinks and
your whiskey dick man I don't know what
it is it's like something but the
morning is just like morning wood well
there's something I think your brain
when it calms down it really likes to
have sex you know and that's why when
you relax yeah when you relax you know I
love getting up in the morning and seein
if my penis it's hard it's like
Christmas for your hand you know I'll
reach down there and see it sometimes I
wake up we would I'm like I can't
believe I still can that 45 still could
get that turned on by I don't know what
nothing but nothing I'm own breathing
usually a lot of times because I breathe
really kind of sexy at night I've been
told that so I'm not shocked that I wake
up yeah you breathe sexy at night yeah
just the way I kind of yeah the way I
kind of women have told me oh if you you
should hear yourself breathing you're
asleep you breathe sexily or you know
sexiest can you can you like I don't
have you know what can you breathe for
me I mean I can try let me see what I
can do
that's hot that is pretty [ __ ] hot
I'm not gonna lie it swim hot women
wait I'm like wait mm ha wim hat was
that wim HOF Joe
yeah the wim HOF cuz the breather guy
yeah oh wait we did that on tour a
little bit it was so funny man like one
one do you put us on to this to wim HOF
and then all these people that he barely
knew was like the second date or is like
we just hired a new whole team every
once in they go they're all like over
these guys look that's real man it
doesn't my dad teaches oh that's worked
for a living he's a breathwork
coaching's 280s I've been around in my
whole life really yeah I had wim on the
podcast too and talked to him about it
and nordley eyed wim HOF on the pot Wow
I've done i swifty he's the homie like
your boy teaches me does breathing with
me sometimes at the gym shout-out to
certified health nut yeah yeah he told
me he's meet up with you so that
technique looked at like that technique
works like you could get high off of
breath work like if you just do that
pattern of Halle Halle tropic breathing
in through the mouth if you lay on the
ground and do that for 20 minutes your
hands will cramp up and you loosen eight
it's free drugs it's free drugs London I
was tired weirdos where do shows in
London I was exhausted and so I would do
that before a bunch of the shows man how
did those shows go we have shows been
good man has been good it gave me like a
breath of fresh air then I went jumped
in the shower just ice cold about a
minute and a half it works man I was it
was just like I'd go into the gym it
just I just needed something to like
make me feel like okay enough to get on
stage well that's my meditate before
every show that helps so much I mean
same same concept yeah it's work those
work those yeah I do it yeah I was a
southerner and in a different interview
of yours I do yeah I'll just do ten
minutes of meditation everyday in the
morning and for me it really it
definitely after a while it gives me a
moment of pause between choices that I
make because usually I'm like real
reactive like whatever's going on I'm
just it's a reaction before I have a
chance to think and then make a choice
you know and so meditation for me gives
me a little bit of that pause in there
where it's like okay can I sound really
smart right now yeah I just read there's
a book called called man's search for
meaning by Viktor Frankl and there's a
quote that he says between stimulus and
response there is a space in that space
is our power to sort of between stimulus
and response there is a space in that
space is our power
to choose [ __ ] I forgot it can you
look it up between stimulus and response
there's a space in that space is our
power to choose our response in our
response lies our growth and our freedom
what that means is that exactly what you
just said Theo
instead of being reactionary in that
moment when you and I had it happen
today I went all the way to the Santa
Monica parking place and I got mad
because I didn't have the right paper
working in that moment I could have
chose to not get upset and be a little
[ __ ] but what I did was I was a little
[ __ ] and I was like [ __ ] I should have
remembered that quote and what Theo was
gonna say later which is in that when
you meditate and you get in that zone
you're not as reactionary and you could
be more of a Jedi [ __ ] and not
just be because it's too easy to just
get pissed off at you so I'm working on
that one so that's the quote that I
always tell myself between stimulus
think about let's break it down between
stimulus and response there's a space so
somebody hits you on the arm right and
you get mad like man [ __ ] you but
instead of getting mad you stop in that
space is our power to choose our
response right so in that moment you can
choose you know I'm not gonna get mad
you let me be I wanna be you let me
think about right of action yeah I even
like it just even in conversation
sometimes it's like sometimes especially
on podcast you get to talk and things
just go and like I say start to become
like this like pentameter kind of words
I mean it's just like I think it's like
a series of notes like a like a series
of notes work or something like it
becomes like a like it's just like a do
I not afloat there's no flow yeah it
comes like I talk you talk I thought you
know just like this beat kind of happens
after a while or something but then I
like it sometimes when yeah there's a
little more space sometimes and you can
just kind of like yeah just gives you a
chance to like come at things from a
different angle sometimes you get stuck
in these kind of something even in
podcasting I noticed that the most
because you're like people feel like we
needed to talk you know I mean I just
like you can just completely clear your
mind out like I made myself go to sleep
off meditation on that no no you taught
me a good lesson Theo taught me a very
good lesson he was my first guest on my
podcast and he told me can I give you a
note I said yeah he's like just just
slow slow down right slow it down and I
mean be operated high levels yeah yeah
last night he thought I was on coke and
I'm like no this is me so yeah right
you don't know I'm I don't I'm this is
sober yeah and I got a slowdown and went
to therapy today and he just kept
telling me slow down because I'm dumping
all this [ __ ] on him he's like slow down
I'm like [ __ ] that's what Theo told me
that's what everyone to it but my brain
goes really fast and I'm a neurotic Jew
mm-hmm so I'm plums that way to stop you
wish but I also that's when I knew
meditate is when my brains going way too
fast I'll have like an idea I'll try to
write it down of another thing come up
oh I got this well my brain wants to do
coat for me it's like oh I need to go
like invest in some property in Detroit
right now I need to go [ __ ] do all
this [ __ ] it's like have you seen Flint
town on Netflix it's a docu-series oh I
want to see I'm on the floor my good
friend said to watch it
David daddy ah damn longneck is from
over there
oh really yeah do Flint town is good man
is that the water problem movie
yeah they got dirty water dude they got
dirty politics everything over there
who's got dirty
I'm going to Michigan in a feud I don't
know when this airs but I'm gonna do a
show in Michigan I love Michigan you
could feel Detroit's having a comeback
you know when you go to certain cities
on tour travel I travel if I was a
billionaire or even a millionaire
there's some cities I go to where I'm
like I would be buying something right
here like you just said yeah Detroit's
one of the cities that's on the come-up
you could feel that same with Reno
yeah Reno you know Reno was the worst
[ __ ] hole ever my mom lives right near
there do you know there I'm like oh she
because Tesla got the [ __ ] there now
that's a place Donnie and maybe I
shouldn't say this on your podcast cuz
it's gonna affect the outcome of of inch
of real estate due to your high output
but it's a fact that these places are
coming up and I just bought a place in
Joshua Tree which I can't wait for you
guys to come out to yeah I want to get
out there something a little hot tub out
there but yeah yeah I want to get out in
it man I got to get out sometimes it's a
balance I think we're all kind of crazy
to do what we do to be in this business
yeah sometimes you got to go oh yeah
it's hard to settle down in this town
let's get this talk here's a question
that came in you guys would be good good
answer to this this man had an issue we
talked about the other day on the
podcast and so this is actually perfect
you guys are here yeah see oh this is
Jeff aka little water socks Colin from
Palm Bay Florida first my daughter and I
were talking
and said we're going to be pretty mad if
you don't come back as uncle baby
Billie's son in the second season of
righteous gemstones I think I've you
fired
thanks I'm asking them but uh yes I'm 36
I rap and sometimes I feel like maybe
it's not as cool to be a 36 year old
rapper as it would be to be like in a
band or maybe gonna stand up you know
comic just wondering it is that weird
like what do you guys think of it is it
weird to be quote unquote on successful
rapper still rapping I love it I'm going
to have a good job I make cheerleading
music actually as it for a living
but you know I speak for kids and all
that but you know I have this little
passion on the side doesn't get too much
love but so happy yeah we're not lambing
nah I think that's cool he makes
cheerleading music I didn't know that
was a thing that he sounds happy didn't
he he's smart for being able to make
cheerleading music right dude first of
all and if he's if he's rapping at that
age I mean any age like if you're making
good [ __ ] then you're you know he's
probably his influences are different
than what most of the kids rappin
nowadays are gonna be so it's gonna be
unique and I think I mean Mattox blew up
cuz he was 12 when you said a rapid and
you blew up so it's like what if there
was a 55 year old rapper putting out
dope ass [ __ ] or a 65 year old rapper
you know yeah so it's like I don't think
age at all matters do you think how much
mark anyway I feel like what do you
think he would have to have a neat spin
like I'm just trying to wonder yeah how
does it guy cuz yeah the way you present
yourself and everything is is part of it
not like I'm saying changes clothes but
his style or we got to see if I was him
I would I would go for like dope ass dad
like dad who's out here flexing like you
know or like yeah I don't even know go
kick maybe be a dad bod go for like dad
bod I actually had a big trademark
dispute where someone else trademark
young gravy before I could it was a
ridiculous amount of money when I knew
so what company was it Hormel it was
snowing it was another kid who tried to
wrap it on him young gravy yeah and he
was like mosquito with like no listens
or anything and I literally had to drop
like probably 170
like lawyer fees and paying them off on
all this [ __ ] just see the name Yan
gravy bag and I was like at one point I
was like I'm just gonna change my name
to Daddy gravy yes I feel like if it's
him he could be daddy whatever you know
I'm saying yeah young gravy got a better
ring note one syllable two syllables
young gravy sounds better yeah dirty
some about the one to two Brad about
that deal on Brad Pitt yeah Johnny Depp
that's it Simon man ray Bob Odenkirk
yeah Jennifer Lopez you know there's a
whole new bob odenkirk I did a show this
weekend in Vegas and he had been to the
show before he'd just gone to the show
whatever the show was before me and he
left a note backstage for he's pretty
nice was it what he said [ __ ] was it
like [ __ ] you yeah it was like yeah
sorry I'm not coming to your show pretty
sweet Bob Odenkirk allege cheer dad the
cheer day yeah maybe he could do
something wild if he's cheer if he got
steer leaders around him I'm trying to
think what he could do he could have a
sick guys dance team behind him if he
just get something nice you know that
dance team right behind him you've
really got a chair coach vibe yeah and
then track suit maybe yeah yes he was
kind of like like that like a like a
Slav squat like a Russian like a hood
like so he's got like the gangster look
with with the tracksuit yeah but he but
he's got hot cheerleaders that's that
you can't go wrong with the hot yeah
you're never gonna get on I forgot why I
put these oh yeah I wanted to talk about
some crazy stories I want to hear some
scary crazy stories or something all
right I want to get it turnt up in here
all right let's go into one they're not
here what do you have one yeah no I'm
gonna hear from the dealer the deep
south as I can tell I'll tell you a
story so they used to have these guys
that would have these parties right and
so they they would have parties around
town and so one time they said okay
we're having a party and so everybody
was all excited you know all weekend
everybody
I'm 39 I mean no over you at the party I
was probably I was probably maybe 14
okay for that we went to the party do
we're excited actually a cop I remember
give us a ride out to the [ __ ] party
how does that work yes he was in our
neighborhood right before he went on
duty
so I'm dating this girl from our
neighborhood and the girl was your girl
was of age I think okay interesting so
it was uh so anyway this cop dropped us
off and we're walking out they had this
huge field between where the party was
it had like a house you hear music and
stuff lights on and you're walking up in
these people this time though it's said
an electric fence right in the middle of
this field it was dark field you didn't
know and uh and people got [ __ ] lit
up doing two of my buddies got lit up
really really good they hit the electric
fence
yeah hit you like if you saw them like a
cartoon like uh you don't see it like
that but you hear them so loud you
almost feel like you can see light no
you know I've I've I haven't done that
but we used to drive out to like the
suburbs of my hometown and like there's
like the farmland [ __ ] and we go party
it like [ __ ] barns and [ __ ] and like
the cops would come and you'd like
everyone everyone would run out into
like the cornfield so I had nights of
like running away through cornfields
with my bros you get hit in the face
with a corn stalk yeah [ __ ] taking
you on a little bit man Owen and you're
out the middle of nowhere like and some
of the girl kept saying oh this ain't
really it's not electric and she went
back and touched it again I remember I
in Texas I shot I shooting music videos
I met this really dope dude it goes by
Brock daddy who was just like his whole
family was like a fan of my music way
early days did I just was like random
fans I'll go stay at their house it was
like back when I could do that oh yeah
and they're really dope and one of his
best friends is like a descendant of the
Campbell Soup family so he's like
billionaire and he has like his own
private Zoo so we went there we shot a
video with like [ __ ] with [ __ ] rhinos
and and giraffes and all that but they
also had like look the biggest
collection of guns ever so we got to
like shoot
Barrett 50 cals grenade launchers and it
was like Brava says some crazy [ __ ] in
Texas you can just get this [ __ ] you
know I'm sure Louisiana is kind of same
no Texas has that man that's Texas okay
man yeah Texas you get big animals
snakes you know you'll have a dude
living a two-bedroom apartment he's got
a [ __ ] rhinoceros in a shower like
they got you know I'm saying Texas has
the craziest the most why like Indian
animals that aren't supposed to be in
America or in Texas yeah I know a friend
of mine is really wealthy from Texas
Nathan annum
like preserve out there we can go
hunting with what like it's like Africa
in America yell out animals that's
correct
so like guns and [ __ ] though those are
obviously easy to get in Louisiana yeah
we had a guy I worked in this farm for a
while and he had this um it was like a
thing I had a laser and it could [ __ ]
saw through a tree it was like an
illegal gun I was like a laser gun or
the laser lined up the bullets or the
laser show the laser you pressed a
button the laser yeah it was insane
that's wild cuz cuz like like I'm most
likely most likely gonna move to Atlanta
in this next year and like I do have
like a number of kind of weird stalkers
that are like crazy you know like I
tried to get a gun in Minnesota because
they were thinning kind of my house and
you can it's so hard so like oh you can
get a gun in Atlanta I'll give one at
the [ __ ] cost no in Georgia it's
pretty easy so like I yeah yeah I mean
just just one you know and a lot of
times we'll go to the studio like in the
hood and I'll be the only one in there
without a strap good thing like I like I
have good friends in Atlanta it'll be
yeah not for me but like at the Marriot
vodka at Marriott Buckhead Atlanta you
can get bullets at the ritz-carlton got
some big asses over there to miss that's
thank you ready for a lot of Eastern
meat oh man I've spent so much time in
Elena already I was done I'm really yeah
I put my uber driver one time she was is
really sexy dark-skinned from where
she's originally from but she was like
one of the caribbean islands and and
yeah man it was it was dope and then i'm
obviously she was driving me around
didn't pay for the ride and then we went
got Waffle House okay so the whole thing
started I was I was leaving a video
shoot it was a Zaytoven music video
shoot with a lil yachty and some and
low-keyed if you know one of them maybe
man I don't know yeah I don't know a
little little keek little keyed okie
he'd so then so then I met these two
girls there and then we didn't hurt it
guy we get an uber to go to Waffle House
and then the uber driver is just like
know what's good and so she comes in to
Waffle House with us and we're like all
in there with bottle of patron and the
the Waffle House people work in there
like drinking with us like look I
started pouring patron into their cups
so drinking with what the employee
and we end up getting our food for free
and then we like she just drops the
other two girls off and I just I clapped
and it was it was awesome and I'm so
staying after there she comes on my
shows in Atlanta and she come out - did
you go to her place you she went came to
your place
uh she came to my friends to my friend's
house and on the couch it was cool Wow
seemed the good friend and I missed
being 23 remember those days I didn't
have a burr back then but let me see she
was she wasn't she was 20 30 no but your
lifestyle
yeah you just like you'll sleep on
somebody's couch shopping for guns
sleeping on couches having sex with
drivers it's must be fun yeah I sit
around going what am i doing my life
yeah I'm gonna try to coach them to how
to go down the right road that's what
I'm gonna do dirts gonna help him out
and yeah I'm not nobody to tell you what
to do or not do I'm the worst person for
life advice but I think I can steer the
ship a little bit and be like don't stay
away from this person don't do that drug
you see it's risky man I appreciate that
it gets risky bro you know and I've
honestly I've had enough like like
experiences where I've learned like I've
been to jail three times I've like how
bad like I've had friends OD I've had
like don like every try like experienced
enough now I think I'm smart you know
like I'm like I'm other than the
fighting [ __ ] that's the last thing I
gotta get over but I'm not getting
getting there yeah maybe you could wear
like yeah or just wear soft gloves or
something after a certain hour yeah
or saw something soft no boxing gloves
getting back out somebody could fight
you right that'll draw the wrong
attention cotton hands it's like some
isotoners yeah something soft bra like a
driving mitt remember driving gloves you
don't see those too often I remember a
lot of Asian women wear them you know in
some Asian cultures driving gloves are a
big thing and you see a lot of actual
drivers like you know fancy drivers a
lot of real rich people if you have a
wooden steering wheel if you're that
rich dude [ __ ] that guy first we'll have
guys a would have a tea arrival dude do
up that's so cool I mean I would pay for
just a sir you should get a wood
steering wheel on the Tesla that's what
I want to do is get I have would grind
everything else ya know but I want to
get is is just like like I was talking
to telling him a Chevelle like a
throwback Chevy and getting those a lot
of those have the wood grain already El
Camino would be nice man oh this morning
with a friend of
remember the steering wheel knob they're
super illegal the knob on the wheel so
you could drive it like this but if it
gets caught on your pants you'll crash
so they made them illegal but you can
still see him in Asia I just saw him
everywhere in Asia but and you know I
realized something men's stereotypes
usually are true within the American
border and maybe Canada but sometimes
stereotypes aren't stereotypes are not
true Asian people can't drive I was just
in Asia they drive amazing I was the one
driving bad and it made me realize wait
a minute I had an epiphany ezp in places
like that where it's like it has a
method to the madness oh I said it slow
perfect it's perfect and then I was like
oh wait a minute maybe Asian people come
to America and they have a hard time
with our way of the way we driving the
rules and the flow but they were
incredible drivers and I was the one who
was like [ __ ] up and it was a reverse
stereotype and I wonder if in Asia
they're like Oh white people can't drive
or Americans can't well I think we in
America is so blocked everything here is
like so it's like blocks you know Darren
Aegeus [ __ ] gets risky you know you're
like this you know this road turns into
a river and 70 feet so you definitely
[ __ ] ready you know they'll have 90
people on motor scooters they love
somebody on a piece of wood somebody on
somebody's back you know yeah dude we
used to play basketball we had a kid
didn't have any legs on our team one
time it's boy Alton Hollins and this
other big kid is big dude on our team
named Terence had to [ __ ] carry him
throughout the game and you know [ __ ]
yeah that's that's that's you and he
finally scored and like the last game
and the worst part was he was the worst
shot so constantly Terence would be
holding him anyway get the shot right
under the [ __ ] goal you miss it every
time after like the seventh or eighth
time you're like man [ __ ] this dude yeah
even though we didn't have legs like the
beginning you're like oh yeah let's get
it for him let's do it for him Rudy
Ruettiger so be a 7-3 if miss you're
like so deterrence and him come by -
what's his name again - no legs Alton
how all didn't Terrance did they come by
you know I can he was homosexual I Boyle
eventually okay he was then - he just
didn't know it but he was not I mean he
was so that's the whole argument we can
have whether or not you're born that way
but my point is born this way I think
he's sweet about it okay my point if it
was five on five did Terrance and him
accumulate to be one person or they two
people no no it counted as that that was
two players oh that's quite an advantage
for the other team yeah so we're at that
point you're kind of down five four but
it was cool man
he's a geek I saw him not too long ago
I'm about four or five years yes sweet
you got great I want that you know be a
cool show would be all these stories
that you have to either I want to I got
AI got a seized some of these characters
you always tell great stories of your
hometown
I just don't know it's yeah sometimes
yeah we just grew up in a wild place man
you say it's called oh just Covington
Lousiana home written and it's what's
the closest big city New Orleans which
is how far private one hour drive or
walk raisi yeah it gets just weird yeah
enough weirdness that comes out of the
city you can walk it would take your
fire out almost over two days after
10:00 we take the 10 runs out a couple
times yeah I walk under the 10 I'd walk
to the movie theater dude we have to
leave at 2:00 p.m. to get there at 7:00
p.m.
remember I lived in Shreveport and I'd
hit you up like this place is a trip and
use like I don't I'm from Louisiana and
I don't go to Shreveport something is it
gets real yeah it just gets real quiet
over there yeah okay I've been losing a
one time for to refer a show and
possibly was New Orleans oh yeah you
know what actually I experienced there
was um this is my story from Louisiana I
I got there I was like soup I don't even
know I was passed out all day I go up in
there like like like put I switched my
meeting retail after the show I walk up
into the green room
there's just dude named kale that like
I'm a good friends with who's like a
dancer dude on Instagram or not phony
ass got kills Kassar rage I don't know
shot damn oh yeah oh you're talking
about yeah country boy yeah yeah kale
sword yeah he pulled up with with his
friends and one of these girls and then
I'm just like I mean I was already kind
of drunk and I was just like I think
within five minutes this girl comes up
to me and she's really pretty and she's
like yo like I gotta show you something
the bathroom and I was like all right I
was like word I'm drunk so then I go I
go up in the bathroom and like within
another three four minutes we're doing
it and in my [ __ ] I look to my left
and my boy savage had been taking a [ __ ]
in the stall so I'm hitting it on the on
the sink
he's in the stall and he's like I'm like
like where you got it you got you like
sneaks out behind and I was kind of like
covering up that whole area but it was
like a real quick it was like the
quickest meeting someone doing it while
your friends [ __ ] and then and then
I found out like and then like within
like 10 minutes later she started show
many pictures of her baby
Oh kid too and I was like well this is
did he courtesy flush we smell like [ __ ]
my rope 25 Nora yeah I have more fun
with minorities quite often oh dude I
love a little I'll get around to a
couple of beautiful Koreans dude and I
can't even contain myself really oh yeah
cuz I'll just get so nervous a lot of
times Korean movies my favorite yeah
they're great movies they make amazing
really yeah I could put you on a few old
boys a good old boys on my favorite I've
tried to watch all but couldn't get into
Oh again everybody was dressed a little
bit like um I felt like those Jehovah's
Witness you know I'm saying a little
Menelaus role movie yeah maybe I did you
better watch the American version yeah
don't watch the American Old Yeller is
what I saw actually oh yeah different
totally different man I think that's
appreciated in today man just I'm pretty
awesome bro yeah don't do anything else
when you go leave huh you gotta leave
yeah how long we going we got 140 that's
a long EPS that's a long-ass episode
that's real long because I'm [ __ ] out
and talk about some more funny [ __ ] uh
no yeah well it's uh he doesn't drink
but but but let's just talk let's cut it
let's call it and keep talking in real
life without recording yeah yeah and can
I be really cheesy I got a plug one
thing yeah I want to tell anyone who's
listening that that is so inclined to go
check out nervous wrecks I'm about to
have you on there I will do on there
yeah I've had some great amazing people
that I know on there and it's I've been
doing it about a year and I'm starting
to get it some really interesting people
I just meet everyone so I'm doing it
yeah you're doing it we got things
nervous wrecks is crazy let's get weird
all tomorrow yeah weird I'm gonna get
baby no money on there yeah oh
absolutely
so it's out there and what about your
any new music you got oh I got every you
always putting out new music that's
what's cool about this new generation
they just put out songs beauty of song
video it's not like it used to be when
we grew up like album a year 12 songs
it's like now it's just putting yeah I
got a single drop in in like three days
and then our album drops Valentine's Day
and then I'm supposed to drop another EP
you told Francis before our tour and the
tour starts March 23rd so you go plug
that's like a within another month right
where we're plugging right now yeah
in the beginning for you guys yeah what
does this come up this will come out
this week mm-hmm tomorrow maybe even
yeah yeah tomorrow well I'll give a
little spec I'll give a little secret
announcement to these listeners because
no one really knows exactly we said
holiday season from the holidays
Valentine's Day mm-hmm so baby gravy too
will be dropping on Valentine's Day
twice the length of the original baby
gravy EP they've been to money young
gravy multiple features and it is some
of our best work yet and then I will be
doing an EP with Dillon Francis for our
tour which starts in March so you all
will be getting a lot of gravy in the
next couple months and if you live in
the south we got about 20 shows in the
south on the store and we got a couple
in the Midwest and like two on the East
Coast so young gravy Dillon Francis Dirt
Nasty it will be at one of the shows as
well yeah I'll be there
gang you'll have to come through yeah oh
yeah my nephew V dude yeah my nephew's
like one of your biggest fans dude he
was going on yeah all calls the boys all
right actually Zimri every now
oh don't perfect thank you for that yeah
America's favorite condiment young gravy
yeah and uh and one of my good friends
Dirt Nasty time erect thank you guys so
much man
Thank You Bailey
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my background I can feel
it enough thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]